politique bonsoir et bienvenue dans
l'hebdopolitique votre rendez-vous du
dimanche soir sur Radio sensation en
association avec TV 78 pour cet épisode
de 220 direction l'Assemblée nationale
mon invité ce soir et le député
renaissance de l'Essonne Alexis Izard
politique
Alexis Isard bonsoir bonsoir vous avez
30 ans et avait été élu en juin dernier
député de la troisième circonscription
de l'Essonne avant cela vous travaillez
chez BPI France en tant que Chargé
d'affaires pour accompagner les
entreprises dans leur développement
votre engagement politique ne date pas
d'hier alors d'abord dans des
associations locales de défense dans
votre ville à Savigny-sur-Orge puis dans
des associations nationales telles que
les jeunes européens ou le Parlement des
étudiants vous vous êtes en suit
présenté donc sous l'étiquette lrem aux
élections municipales de
Savigny-sur-Orge en 2020 et en 2021 mais
aussi pour les élections départementales
dans le canton de toujours de Savigny en
juin 2021 vous avez enfin connu la
victoire
aux législatives ailleurs qu'à Savigny
dans la troisième circonscription de
l'Essonne alors quelles sont les
premières impressions que vous avez eu
donc en entrant au Palais Bourbon avec
siéger avec tous les représentants de la
nation alors effectivement je vous
remercie pour ce dérouler je vais
ajouter que mon engagement effectivement
il a d'abord commencé par de
l'associatif tout d'abord comme beaucoup
de jeunes dans des clubs sportifs où je
me suis d'abord épanoui en tant que
pratiquant puis en essayant
d'accompagner puis après ce goût de
l'engagement qui fait progressivement
s'engage pour son club pour sa ville
puis petit à petit on goûte à la
politique et on arrive comme là
maintenant à l'Assemblée nationale donc
mes premiers ressentis sur sur cette sur
cette assemblée c'est déjà une une
grande responsabilité qui nous est
donnée on le sent en arrivant le choix
de nos commissions j'ai eu la chance
d'être intégré dans la commission des
affaires économiques qui étaient
cohérentes avec vous l'avez décrit mon
parcours professionnel tout de suite
beaucoup de responsabilités qui nous
sont donnés la capacité d'agir et donc
une bonne une bonne intégration dans un
groupe que je suis très heureux auquel
je suis très heureux d'appartenir et
j'ajoute que vous avez été pendant un
moment aussi le référent départemental
de la République en marche en Essonne
mais maintenant il faut dire Renaissance
c'est officiel donc depuis le 17
septembre et le congrès du parti au
Louvre le nouveau sec manière générale
du parti et donc Stéphane séjourné déjà
présents du groupe Renaissance au
Parlement européen alors l'objectif pour
lui ce sera de préparer l'après Macron
vous avez pleinement confiance en cette
nouvelle direction pour cela alors j'ai
pleinement confiance en Stéphane cette
journée j'ajouterai que je suis toujours
référent dans marche maintenant
Renaissance en Essonne jusqu'à la
réaction du nouveau bourreau donc je
fais entièrement confiance à Stéphane
séjourné pour reconstituer ce nouveau
parti qui est une une pierre importante
fondatrice de la suite de l'après Macron
mais du pendant Macron aussi pour
rassembler une force politique centrale
dont on a besoin actuellement avec une
un
des extrêmes qui se développent
énormément que ce soit à droite comme à
gauche on a besoin d'un pôle central qui
qui concentre des idées fortes on parle
beaucoup du plein emploi de l'éducation
des thématiques sur lesquelles on a
envie de se retrouver et d'avancer donc
je lui fais extrêmement confiance et je
fais aussi confiance à tous les
militants qui sont présents les
référents les militants qui sont
présents sur le terrain et qui savent
très bien travaillé ensemble qu'ils le
font déjà depuis 2017 et qui vont
continuer à le faire jusqu'à jusqu'à la
suite alors Stéphane c'est journée a
déjà prévenu que la vocation du nouveau
parti Renaissance ce sera de présenter
un candidat en 2027 mais derrière vos
alliés du modèle et d'horizon ont aussi
leurs ambitions et leurs Philippe à
snober le Conseil national de la
refondation et François bayraud a
expliqué ne pas vouloir donc de passage
en force sur la réforme des retraites
est-ce que la maison commune est déjà en
train de s'effriter un petit peu je vais
vous le dire opérationnellement à
l'Assemblée sur le terrain à la maison
commune elle fonctionne très bien il
faut pas être naïf on est dans un monde
politique c'est normal qu'il y ait
quelques tensions ou quelques
discussions et qui apparaissent parfois
de manière
inopportunes dans la presse en tout cas
chacun travaille ensemble moi je vais
vous le dire à l'Assemblée nationale on
travaille tous ensemble que ce soit le
modem horizon territoire de progrès tous
les partenaires et Renaissance on
travaille ensemble sur le terrain les
militants savent travailler ensemble ils
vont militer ensemble et ils travaillent
cette implantation donc non je peux vous
dire qu'il y a aucune fissure dans cette
maison commune et elle est au travail
alors sur les prochains travaux de
l'Assemblée au final justement le projet
de loi de finances va bientôt vous être
soumis les oppositions ont déjà refusé
de dialoguer à Bercy avec le ministre du
Budget Gabriel Attal alors dans la
majorité les avis sont partagés et
regiver lui plait pour faire passer la
réforme des retraites dans un amendement
donc du projet de loi de Finances
François Bayrou lui veut éviter tout
passe en force sur le sujet alors est-ce
que c'est le bon moment ou pas pour
établir cette réforme de retraite alors
là vous demandez mon avis personnel
étant donné que la discussion elle est
elle est encore en cours par nature je
suis pas un un grand fan du passage en
force en revanche ce que je vais vous
dire c'est que cette réforme des
retraites elle a été portée dans le
programme de 2017 lorsque Emmanuel
Macron a été élu elle a été portée dans
le programme d'Emmanuel Macron en 2022
lorsqu'il a été élu c'est une réforme
qui est peut-être un populaire parce
qu'elle est peut-être mal expliquée je
crois qu'il faut qu'on la travaille bien
ça a été fait pendant le précédent
quinquennat il faut qu'on la présente
bien qu'on a fonce toutes les toutes les
les avancées sociales qui sont dans
cette réforme là et qu'on arrive à la
faire accepter aux Français parce que
cette réforme elle est extrêmement
importante pour nos finances publiques
mais aussi pour les inventés sociales et
pour euh je dirais aller combler un
manquement de beaucoup de monde que ce
soit les les les carrières discontinues
ou les minimum retraite qui sont qui
sont trop bas donc une revalorisation
beaucoup d'avancées sociales il faut la
faire cette réforme alors sur la forme
casserait la meilleure méthode pour la
faire cette réforme la concertation avec
les oppositions ça semble un peu
compliqué vu les premiers retours un
amendement par l'article 49-3 qui permet
au gouvernement de faire passer
directement une loi encore une fois ça
aurait fait ex-co avec ce que je vous ai
juste avant le 49-3 personne n'est un
grand aficionados du 49.3 et si vous
regardez le précédent mandat
n'a jamais été utilisé concerter
discuter essayer de convaincre les
oppositions priorité et la concertation
et le travail avec les oppositions
visiblement les oppositions pour
l'instant n'ont pas envie de travailler
avec nous n'ont pas envie d'avancer je
vois mal cependant un électorat de
droite s'opposer à une réforme des
retraites qu'il porte depuis des années
donc je crois que le travail de le
travail de discussion le travail de
concertation il doit être mené fermement
avec ses partenaires-là quitte à faire
des avancées dans leur sens c'est
vraiment le cœur de cette de cette
concertation c'est le cœur de la de la
consultation c'est pour ça qu'il faut
travailler ensemble et j'ai bonne
confiance qu'on arrive à trouver un
terrain d'entente sur ces sujets-là si
c'est pas le cas il faudra avancer alors
sur le budget vous avez été nommé
rapporteur pour avis sur les
investissements d'avenir alors est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire un peu plus
sur ce rôle cette mission et comment
est-ce que vous allez vous vous y
prendre oui bien sûr alors dans le cadre
du du projet de loi finance à venir le
projet de loi finance il est travaillé
dans la commission des finances donc
c'est la Commission qui traite sur le
fond ces sujets là et tous les sujets
qui ont à faire avec les commissions
tous les sujets qui peuvent ressembler
aux commissions à côté donc moi les
affaires économiques sont traitées pour
avis sur au sein de ces commissions donc
moi je suis chargé de traiter un avis
budgétaire sur ces investissements
d'avenir là donc mon rôle est d'aller
donner un avis budgétaire sur des
thématiques qui me sont chères moi j'ai
choisi la batterie électrique par
rapport au problématique qu'on peut
avoir sur mon territoire avec notamment
Renaud Lardy j'ai choisi l'agriculture
évidemment quelque chose de très
important pour notre département et la
santé du futur qui touche évidemment
tous les Français donc mon rôle est
d'auditionné actuellement différents
acteurs de ces de ces de ces industries
pour me faire un avis sur la performance
bun ou mauvaise des précédentes
politiques et d'essayer d'améliorer au
mieux cette loi alors l'actualité
internationale elle est marquée aussi
par la crise énergétique conséquence du
conflit en Ukraine alors que les
importations de gaz russe ont plongé au
cours de ces six derniers mois mais
comme partout en Europe la France se
prépare à faire face à une situation
énergétique exceptionnelle alors
l'occasion de refaire un point sur notre
situation énergétique actuellement la
France a 56 réacteurs nucléaires mais 27
sont à l'arrêt EDF a promis de
redémarrer durant l'hiver
progressivement vous avez d'ailleurs
auditionné le PDG d'EDF sur l'état du
parc nucléaire français alors où est-ce
qu'on on est sur la situation
énergétique alors effectivement vous
l'avez rappelé on a pu auditionner le
patron d'EDF mais aussi drte et
l'ensemble des ministres du gouvernement
chargé de ces sujets énergétiques le
patron d'EDF est plutôt confiant sur le
fait de la réouverture de ces centrales
avant l'hiver les dernières réouvertures
se feront au cours de janvier il faut se
rassurer sur le fait également que vous
ne parlez du gaz la plupart de nos
réserves sont faites avant l'hiver donc
il devrait potentiellement pas y avoir
de gros sujets sur cette hivir là mais
il faut rester il faut rester vigilant
et c'est pour cette raison de cet hiver
non pas de la chaos cet hiver et c'est
pour cette raison qu'on qu'on met en
avant la sobriété la sobriété choisie
plutôt qu'imposer plus que c'est ce qui
a été dit pendant la discussion la
sobriété choisie plutôt que la la
coupure imposée donc si chaque français
arrive à faire un effort il y a eu déjà
des des essais dans certaines régions si
chaque Français chaque entreprise
collectivité arrive à diminuer un petit
peu le chauffage à diminuer à rénover
ses bâtiments pour gagner en sobriété de
10 ça nous permettra de passer l'hiver
amplement parce qu'avec le recul vous
regrettez la décision qui a été prise en
2018 notamment de fermer la centrale de
Fessenheim par la majorité Emmanuel
Macron avait à l'époque également
annoncé la fermeture progressive de 14
réacteurs nucléaires d'ici à 2035 dont 4
d'ici à 2030 donc finalement ce ne sera
pas le cas est-ce que vous regrettez
cette décision mon rôle n'est pas de
regretter une décision qui a été prise
alors que je n'exercais aucune fonction
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
va investir plus d'un milliard d'euros
pour créer des SMS des réacteurs de
petites de petites capacités donc on
investit massivement dans le nucléaire
on le développe on maintient notre notre
indépendance on maintient en contrôle
notre indépendance énergétique et je
pense que c'est ce qui compte alors à
l'époque on disait que le nucléaire
c'était pas c'est c'était très critiqué
sur les questions environnementales
aujourd'hui c'est tout le contraire donc
on va on part dans limite dans l'autre
sens on évoque la construction de 6 à 14
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires génération
en dépit donc des critiques
environnementales il faut travailler en
ce sens c'est
il faut pas être naïf sur le sujet du
nucléaire le nucléaire c'est la
problématique c'est c'est les déchets
c'est l'entretien de celle-ci il faut
pas être naïf dans le sens où c'est pas
une une énergie parfaite mais
actuellement dans ce qu'on est capable
de créer dans ce qu'on est capable de
faire c'est la plus parfaite donc il
faut s'en servir pour axer notre
transition notre transition énergétique
il s'avère qu'on a besoin d'énergie ça
fait de nombreuses années qu'on essaye
de de compenser le nucléaire avec un peu
plus d'énergie renouvelable aujourd'hui
il faut additionner l'énergie
renouvelable au nucléaire qu'on dispose
donc on dispose parce que on a un besoin
de souveraineté les guerres en Europe on
ne s'imaginait pas qu'elle pourrait
revenir aujourd'hui elles font face on
est obligé de faire face à ça assez
problématiques là donc faut pas être
naïf une énergie qu'il faudra à terme
peut-être réussir à combler avec quelque
chose de plus sûr mais actuellement et
j'encovici le rappeler assez assez
clairement lors d'une émission télévisée
un problème dans une dans un pour un
vrai problème de réacteur nucléaire
c'est c'est ce qui s'est passé à
Fukushima c'est une grosse explosion et
c'est le la centrale qui qui pète c'est
pas Tchernobyl donc il faut pas non plus
avoir des des craintes qui soit
irrationnels mais il faut pas non plus y
aller avec une certaine candeur sans
penser au conséquences mais c'est
important aussi pour notre indépendance
énergétique totalement sur la question
environnementale cette semaine Elisabeth
borne a présenté un nouveau plan vélo
donc 250 millions pour l'année 2023
c'est la moitié de ce qui avait été mis
sur les cinq dernières années au total
500 millions sur l'ensemble du dernier
quinquennat l'objectif est de favoriser
la pratique de la bicyclette notamment
dans la construction avec la
construction de pistes cyclables dans
des zones périurbaines ou rurales des
zones qui ressemblent à votre
circonscription d'ailleurs que
pensez-vous de ce nouveau plan vélo moi
je m'en félicite c'est une très bonne
chose pour deux points tout d'abord le
continuer à construire des
infrastructures pour le vélo qu'on
puisse pratiquer le maximum possible le
plus en sécurité possible donc ça c'est
une super c'est une super nouvelle et
aussi sur la filière de construction de
vélo qu'on arrive à construire en France
des vélos ce qui est pas le cas
aujourd'hui donc c'est un super plan qui
est mis en place je suis très content
qu'on accélère c'est pas nouveau c'est
on en est au 3e 4e plan vélo donc c'est
pas nouveau on continue cette ambition
là et c'est super que ça fonctionne le
budget en tout cas est augmenté sur la
construction d'une filière donc de vélo
made in France c'est bon pour les
emplois aussi évidemment évidemment on a
une excellence dans le vélo français
donc il faut y aller il faut continuer
enfin la construction de parking à vélo
sera aussi financée par ce plan dans
l'optique des JO 2024 alors est-ce que
le l'objectif c'est de ressembler à
Amsterdam
je sais pas si l'objectif c'est de
ressembler à Amsterdam je pense que
l'objectif c'est de ressembler à Paris
et de pouvoir
maximiser le pousser le français le plus
possible à utiliser des moyens de
locomotion qui soit décarbonée
alors nous sommes toujours avec Alexis
Isard député renaissance de la troisième
circonscription de l'Essonne et on va
passer maintenant à des sujets plus
locaux politiques
Alexis Zard vous avez été élu en juin
dernier avec 51,18 % députés de la
troisième circonscription de l'Essonne
elle comporte 47 communes et va d'est en
ouest de Brétigny à Dourdan une
circonscription assez vaste quels sont
les problématiques que vous avez
identifiées au cours de cette campagne
les problématiques elles sont nombreuses
sur sur une circonscription comme la
mienne étant donné que vous l'avez
rappelé on parle d'une ville
urbaine comme Brétigny jusqu'à des
villes beaucoup plus rurales en passant
par Dourdan Étréchy donc c'est une
circonscription qui est qui est très
représentative de la France avec tous
ces problèmes on parlait tout à l'heure
des transports un problème massif sur
tout le département de l'Essonne et en
particulier sur la circonscription
l'accès aux soins également et l'accès à
l'emploi l'accès à l'emploi c'est un
sujet sur lequel je me suis je me suis
particulièrement engagé parce que c'est
les sujets sur lesquels je suis le plus
compétent
et qui inclut également toutes ces
thématiques là les thématiques
précédentes que je viens de citer
l'accès à l'emploi de qualité sur la
circonscription c'est un gros un gros
sujet auquel j'aimerais travailler
massivement
le département de l'Essonne c'est porté
volontaire pour expérimenter une
nouvelle réforme celle du RSA alors
l'idée c'est que donc l'état soumettre
le versement de la prestation à de
nouvelles conditions avec la réalisation
de leur travail on parle d'un contrat
d'engagement entre donc l'état et donc
les bénéficiaires une réforme assez
controversée notamment à gauche cette
réforme est-ce que vous y êtes favorable
je suis plus que favorable certains
aimeraient dire que le travail est
droite je l'ai entendu vous l'avez
certainement entendu aussi moi je crois
que le retour à l'emploi il est
nécessaire nécessaire pour pour
n'importe qui pour vivre dignement de
son de son de son travail en Essonne on
a déjà commencé avec certains
dispositifs je pense notamment à
Brétigny où on accompagne les les
demandeurs d'emploi vers la recherche
avec des formations ciblées l'idée c'est
d'accompagner c'est je crois 31.500
demandeurs
bénéficiaires bénéficiaires du RSA vers
l'emploi c'est une très bonne chose ces
personnes là demandent que ça de réussir
à trouver trouver un emploi donc bien
sûr j'en suis plus que favorable et le
département des zona aussi mis en place
la plateforme job 91 pour mettre en
relation les différents acteurs alors
vous pouvez donc peut-être aussi donc à
citer de près à cette cette
expérimentation en Essonne vous
souhaitez c'est le département soit
sélectionné non seulement je le souhaite
mais je vais pousser pour que ce soit le
cas
on verra donc ça le département de
l'Essonne a également fait parler de lui
la semaine dernière en lançant un appel
d'offre auprès des chasseurs alors pour
réguler la faune sauvage sur ses espaces
naturels ça a provoqué la colère de
l'opposition départementale de gauche le
contrat représente 200000 euros max sur
4 ans alors est-ce que vous trouvez ça
normal alors que généralement c'est
plutôt les chasseurs qui payent pour
pour pouvoir chasser normalement il paye
entre 100 à 150 euros par jour en
moyenne en Essonne parce que c'est
normal non c'est la première fois que ça
arrive est-ce que c'est justifié oui le
sujet est que on parle principalement de
sanglier qui qui détériore les champs
des agriculteurs donc il y avait une
problématique il fallait trouver une
réponse le Conseil départemental que je
ne défends pas mais que j'incrimine pas
non plus à décider que la meilleure
solution pour aider ces agriculteurs là
c'était de souscrire à un contrat avec
des chasseurs une société privée pour
pour
et pour prélever cette espèce donc je
crois que c'est une solution d'urgence
qui a été prise et qui
qui est nécessaire pour pour les
habitants
donc le RER C maintenant à présent un
sujet qui a un RER que vous connaissez
bien puisque vous avez prise de
nombreuses reprises entre à l'époque
entre Savigny et Paris vous travaillez
donc
depuis pas encore continue à le prendre
vous continuez toujours à le prendre
justement donc le RER C 19 trains
supprimé en ce mois de septembre ça pose
de nombreux problèmes à de nombreux
utilisateurs bien sûr alors c'est une
problématique très très importante sur
lesquelles je peux vous assurer que les
parlementaires d'Île-de-France sont
mobilisés on se réunit autour de nos
conseillers régionaux parce qu'il faut
savoir que la compétence des transports
est détenue par par le Conseil Régional
donc on travaille on a des cellules de
travail avec les parlementaires
d'Île-de-France plus les conseillers
régionaux on essaye de proposer des des
solutions pour améliorer le service de
transport on peut pas demander de
décarboner nos
de demander aux Français d'utiliser moi
leur voiture et à côté de ça d'avoir des
trains qui ne circulent pas une fois sur
deux et qui nous permettent pas d'être
certain d'arriver à l'heure au travail
pour finir parlons des problèmes
d'affectation que connaissent certains
lycéens et Sonia alors pour le moment
près de 900 élèves n'ont reçu aucune
affectation adaptée à leur culture alors
cursus dans le secteur dans leur secteur
de scolarité faute de place donc la
majorité se situe à Corbeil-Essonnes
mais à Dourdan aussi dans votre
circonscription il y a eu des problèmes
notamment au lycée Tesla alors est-ce
que cette situation est acceptable en
2022 elle est pas acceptable cette
situation elle est en cours des
résolutions mais ce qu'il faut ce sur
quoi il faut s'interroger c'est de
rentrer suivantes est-ce que nos lycées
sont assez grands est-ce que nos
collèges sont assez grands en
l'occurrence la solution qui était
donnée c'est toutes les affectations qui
ne sont pas qui ne sont pas faites les
élèves pourraient redoubler finalement
en troisième c'est pas acceptable pour
des élèves qui ont fait leur preuve qui
ont obtenu leur brevet des collèges donc
il y a une vraie question mais c'est une
vraie question politique pour le coup de
savoir est-ce qu'il faut construire plus
de lycées pour ces demandes là sachant
qu'on est à
on est à un pic du nombre d'étudiants
qui arrivent dans ces lycéens donc il
faut pas prendre des décisions qui
soient hâtives sur des constructions qui
ne serviraient plus à rien une fois le
pic passé mais il faut trouver des
solutions rapides pour qu'on ne n'ait
plus à revivre 900 élèves de 3e qui se
retrouvent sans affectation un sujet
extrêmement important qui est traité au
plus haut dans notre département en tout
cas pour finir cette émission Alexis
Isard quand on est député ont donc au
bout de n'étiez pas à la base donc sur
cette circonscription vous n'étiez pas
implanter on va voir les mers on va se
présenter on se fait connaître comment
comment on s'y prend pour pour se faire
accepter par une population alors vous
clôturez la boucle avec le début moi
j'étais référent départemental donc de
la majorité présidentielle sur le
département de l'Essonne donc le
département de l'Essonne et un
département que je connais très bien mon
engagement je vous disais il a commencé
au niveau local mais il a très vite été
estonien donc je dois dire que
l'ensemble du territoire je le je le
connais bien je me suis beaucoup
intéressé au sud de l'Essonne sur les
dernières années parce que j'ai
on fait le constat que politiquement le
nord de l'Essonne était toujours très
représenté le sud de l'Essonne était
toujours délaissé donc ce côté
urbain contre ruralité qui a toujours
qui a toujours toujours eu un impact
important
est un peu à la circonscription est à la
frontière là donc les grandes des
grosses villes comme Brétigny exactement
Corbreuse ou le Val-Saint-Germain par
exemple exactement où Châtillon ville
donc effectivement donc ce gel ce sujet
là je l'avais déjà traité et je
connaissais déjà très bien la
circonscription effectivement quand on
devient élu parlementaire le sujet c'est
d'être le plus proche possible de
l'ensemble des élus et de l'ensemble des
administrés donc c'est d'être présent
sur le terrain dès que le temps nous le
permet et je vous assure que c'est des
journées qui commencent le lundi à 6h et
qui finissent le lundi à 5h59 la
différence de certains députés comme
parisien notamment votre circonscient
vous c'est 47 communes alors comment on
fait pour pouvoir c'est énormément de
déplacement c'est énormément de de
sujets différents à traiter j'imagine
oui c'est beaucoup de beaucoup beaucoup
de déplacement vous vous dites vrai je
prends l'exemple des forums des
associations où on a envie de rencontrer
le tissu associatif ces personnes qui
ont envie de nos communes c'est pas
possible effectivement alors on a on a
une vingtaine de forums des associations
qui ont lieu en même temps on essaye de
se démultiplier au maximum et ensuite on
contacte les associations pour pouvoir
les rencontrer l'idée c'est de donner le
maximum de son temps de pallier les
situations où on peut pas se rendre à
deux événements en rencontrant les
personnes les personnes plus tard c'est
quelque chose qui se fait et c'est
quelque chose qui est nécessaire pour
notre travail législatif parce qu'il
faut pas oublier que si on est élu par
un territoire c'est pour les représenter
dans la manière dont on fait la loi à
Paris et on refait le lien à ce que je
veux raconter tout à l'heure la manière
dont j'ai traité mes investissements
d'avenir en choisissant l'agriculture la
batterie la santé du futur elle s'est
principalement faite via les différentes
rencontres que j'ai eu sur mon
territoire et où je me suis dit que là
il y avait quelque chose à faire alors
là député précédente Laetitia Romero
Diaz avait effectué un circo tour il y a
il y a maintenant un an vous comment
est-ce que vous allez vous y prendre
avec les citoyens pour rester en contact
pour rester proche de la population
justement actuellement je suis très
présent sur l'ensemble des l'ensemble
des événements de la circonscription
j'ai la chance d'être sur une très belle
circonscription avec beaucoup
d'événements qui ont lieu des fêtes une
capacité de rencontrer beaucoup de monde
et ça c'est super moi ce que je souhaite
mettre en place et qui vont arriver là
dans les dans les jours qui arrivent
c'est des cafés parlementaires pour
rencontrer le maximum d'habitants
possible et que les les habitants de la
circonscription puissent faire remonter
leurs attentes parlementaires pour pour
faire la loi à Paris et pouvoir
travailler avec eux échanger leur faire
savoir mes ambitions mes intentions
concernant les lois à venir et amender
avec avec leurs idées et pour finir la
tâche
de député la quantité de travail est-ce
que on a conscience de ça quand on est
par exemple citoyen ce qu'on peut avoir
conscience quelle est la charge de
quantité de travail justement
sincèrement
ça fait assez longtemps que je suis dans
les dans l'écosystème j'ai vu les
parlementaires travailler énormément je
pense qu'il faut devenir parlementaire
pour se rendre compte de la tâche que ça
représente maintenant c'est un mandat
qui est passionnant qui nous prend tout
notre temps qui nous prend tout notre
temps du lundi au dimanche mais qui est
passionnant qui est fait de rencontre et
de travail de fonds qui nous permet de
voir un horizon extrêmement large donc
effectivement les journées sont denses
mais on
en donnerait pas une minute vous êtes
encore un jeune député est-ce que il y a
par exemple il y a des députés donc qui
peuvent proposer des lois ce qui est un
sujet particulier qui qui va vous
intéresser sur laquelle vous avez
travaillé ou pour l'instant vous n'avez
pas encore pour l'instant je suis
intéressé par tous les sujets
économiques c'est pour ça que j'ai
commencé à travailler sur les
investissements d'avenir moi je vous le
disais bon mon mon mon point de
compétence mon dada c'est c'est
d'accompagner les entreprises
d'accompagner les PME d'accompagner les
ETI les aider à se développer en France
les aider à partir à l'international
comme j'ai pu faire de mon ancien
travail donc moi ce que j'aime c'est ce
projet qu'on a de réindustrialiser la
France d'accompagner nos entreprises à
créer à embaucher c'est vraiment là
dessus que je m'épanouis et c'est
là-dedans que je vais que je vais
travailler en tout cas au niveau
parlementaire on peut aller puisqu'il
nous reste encore encore une minute
trente sur la commission donc vous êtes
donc commissaire aux Affaires
économiques quel comment est-ce que vous
avez fait ce choix comment est-ce que ça
a été fait donc au sein des comment ça a
été choisi au sein des députés donc il y
a plusieurs commissions la commission
des affaires étrangères la commission
des affaires économiques dont vous
faites partie la commission de la
défense aussi comment est-ce que tout ça
se met en place si vous voulez rentrer
dans les coulisses de de l'arrivée d'un
jeune député quand on arrive député on
siège au sein d'un groupe les places
dans les commissions sont réparties dans
tous les groupes et nous on vient nous
demander quels sont vos à l'instar d'un
lycéen quelles sont vos choix dans
quelle commission vous aimeriez siéger
ou vous épanouir le plus numéro 2
numéro 3 justifiez votre choix moi j'ai
choisi la commission des affaires
économiques parce que mon profil
professionnel à ça et mes ambitions
législatives les ambitions de de travail
qui correspondait j'ai été entendu et je
suis très heureux de l'avoir été bien
merci beaucoup merci à vous alexisarde
d'avoir été avec nous danse de politique
je rappelle donc que vous êtes député
Renaissance il faut dire comme ça
maintenant de la troisième
circonscription de l'Essonne et nous on
se retrouve bientôt pour un nouveau
numéro de libre de politique bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]